bonsoir 3è débat concernant les
départementales sur TVfil 78 ce soir
nous nous intéressons au canton de
plaisir qui compte donc les communes de
plaisir les clés sousbîes hiver
valgrinon et ben un canton entre
urbanité et ruralité entre développement
économique et préservation des terres
agricoles je vous rappelle les derniers
résultats en 2008 le canton était
composé uniquement des villes de plaisir
et des clés sous-bois il y avait six
candidats en LCE un deuxième tour qui
avait oppos é Jean-Michel Gourdon
candidat de la gauche et Véronique
cotémillard merudi des clés sous bois et
Jean-Michel Gourdon l'avait emporté avec
plus de 60 % des suffrages le conseiller
général sortant Jean-Michel Gourdon a
fait le choix de ne pas se représenter
c'est vous Nicolas bonsoir qui faites
campagne avec Frédéric Érard pour le
Parti de Gauche autrees candidat à vos
côtés Patricia Charton bonsoir pour les
vers vous êtes associé à Gérard Lévi et
Jamel Nati bonsoir pour le Front de
Gauche en bénô avec Marise mierre bons
vous font face pour ce débat Joséphine
Berg bonsoir vous êtes maire UMP de
plaisir vous êtes candidate union de la
droite avec Bruno cocard udi Fabien met
bonsoir vous êtes candidat debout la
France en binô avec Pascal Michard et
Éric Gou bonsoir vous êtes candidat
Front national associé à Estelle de
Oliviera je vous précise juste que vos
temps de paroles seront chronométrés ils
vous seront communiqués aussi
régulièrement ma première question un
tour de table selon un dernier sondage
TNS offrait 57 % des Français déclarent
ne pas s'intéresser au départemental
alors qu'est-ce que vous auriez vous
envie de dire aux électeurs pour aller
voter le Dimanche 22 mars Nicolas u moi
je voudrais simplement leur dire que
nous avons vécu des événements il y a
quelques mois de ça il y a 2 mois tout
juste qui ont proné enfin qui nous ont
fait prener tous ensemble et de manière
concertée le vivre ensemble et que le
département est un élément essentiel
dans ce vivre ensemble puisque il a pour
compétence notamment l'action sociale
l'éducation ou bien l'aménagement du
territoire et que ces manières enfin ces
moyens pour vivre ensemble peuvent être
développés au sein de ces trois
compétences et que lorsque l'on a vu la
mobilisation qu'il y a eu le 11 janvier
dernier il faut la la faire perdurer la
faire perdurer dans les urnes le 22 mars
et le 29 mars
prochain nécessité de proximité le
département c'est encore je dirais une
strate qui nous permet d'avoir un
rapport proche de de l'habitant et du
Citoyen aujourd'hui on se rend compte
combien juste justement les citoyens ont
besoin de cette proximité aujourd'hui le
département a vraiment pour rôle d'être
dans cette dans cette attache dans cette
approche au niveau du social
particulièrement de toutes ces personnes
qui ont de vraies difficultés au niveau
de l'intergénérationnel au niveau des
collèges et au niveau du du territoire
par rapport à toutes les routes
départementales pour ne citer que cela
bien évidemment donc il faut bien
rappeler à tout le monde qu'il est
indispensable de ne pas perdre cette
strate patri Charton
euh exactement le même genre de de
d'information on est on est vraiment au
niveau du département dans dans dans une
un un niveau qui permet de de créer
encore du lien social qui qui est
beaucoup plus difficile à créer au
niveau de la région euh avec des moyens
bien supérieurs à celui de la commune
donc donc forcément euh plus adapté avec
des compétences qui sont bien ciblées et
qui peuvent se se recouvrer euh par
rapport à la gestion du territoire par
exemple parce que les terres agric cole
on peut gérer ça au niveau des
départements mais il y a une vision
générale au niveau de la région hein
donc on est très attaché chez écologie à
au niveau écologique justement à ce que
l'urbanisme ne ne mange pas ces ces
territoires agricoles et faire en sorte
aussi de pouvoir revenir à une autonomie
alimentaire sur nos territoires qui
n'existe pas on a 90 % de ce que l'on
mange ici est importé depuis le reste de
la France ou ou d'ailleurs tu bien oui
enfin c'est c'est vrai que c'est un
constat malheureux de voir les gens se
détourner des des urnes c'est pour moi
c'est un échec un échec des politiques
dans leur ensemble mais après je je peux
que comprendre cette désaffection en
voyant le spectacle de bas niveau qu'on
peut
voir le enfin le spectacle que nous
offre nos ites et aussi il y a un point
qui joue c'est le manque d'information
on voit que les gens sont relativement
peu informés de ces élections là qui
sont pourtant comme comme tout le monde
le dit très importantes par que le
département est un acteur social euh
primordial au même titre que la commune
ou la région et on voit vraiment que
tout ceci est dû à pour moi à ces deux
effets là combinés qui font que
malheureusement en effet les gens se
démobilisent j lati oui enfin le constat
est le même que que mes que mes collègu
ici présents on a l'impression
véritablement tout est fait pour ne pas
intéresser les gens bien évidemment
aujourd'hui il a pas de débat on voit
des sondages s vous êtes là ce soir oui
exception l'exception oui effectivement
au niveau national vous avvez raison de
me reprendre sur le sujet et et je vous
en remercie de de de de nous convier et
de pouvoir échanger mais le constat est
quand même qu'au niveau national rien
n'est fait pour intéresser les gens mais
il faut les comprendre aussi hein quand
on voit le dé triricotage qui a été fait
avec un moment on parlait de de de de de
supprimer le Conseil des conseil général
avant de le transformer en conseil
territorial aujourd'hui rien n'est fait
pour intéresser les gens je veux dire on
a l'impression que c'est c'est c'est
c'est voulu donc par contre il y a un
point extrêmement important ce que je
pourrais soulever le côté éit positif
c'est bah déjà on met en place la parité
la vraie parité ça c'est vraiment un
point positif ce qui n'était pas le cas
après derrière on pourra en discuter sur
la mise en œuvre effectivement mais sur
le sur le fond ça c'est c'est important
après un point qui est vraiment négatif
c'est cette approche de bipartisme
encore une fois quand on voit le mode de
scrutin je comprends mais con citoyens
qui ont du mal à saisir la pertinence et
autres il faut avoir fait vraiment de
longues études des études brillantes
hein sur le sujet pour réussir à trouver
à trouver comment tout ça va se va se
passer donc après je ne pourrais rien
rajouter d'autre je passe après mes
chers mes chers collègues sur le sujet
effectivement c'est la proximité c'est
une strate indispensable je ve dire
quand on VO aujourd'hui qu'on essaie de
nous parler du Grand Paris toutes ces
choses là qui sont bien éloignées du
territoire c'est forcément indispensable
de garder cette proximité c'est l'étage
intermédiaire avec la région et les on
va dire les les les missions qui sont
confié au Conseil Territorial sont
indispensables au bon fonctionnement ça
permet notamment d'échanger et d'éviter
ce désert et de cette désaffection du du
citoyen par rapport à la chose politique
éou moi je souhaite leur dire qu'il n'y
a pas de petit petite élection donc et
même qu'au contraire derrière des
élections qui semblent un petit peu
négligées par nos élites
puisqueaujourd'hui on sait pas encore
complètement le le périmètre du futur
conseil
départemental leur dire qu'il y a des
gros projets qui se qui sont qui sont
sous-jacents et qui notamment tout le
monde est est d'accord apparemment pour
dire que le département c'est quelque
chose d'important il y a effectivement
un détricotage qui se prépare puisqu'on
il semble qu'on aille vers d'ici
l'horizon 2020 à des hyper régions et
donc du coup un manque de proximité pour
le coup on va parler maintenant des des
compétences si vous voulez bien parce
que effectivement vous dites on sait pas
trop l'avenir du conseil général comment
il va se dessiner c'est actuellement en
discussion au Parlement alors quelles
doivent être d'après vous les les
compétences indispensables du conseil
général de de demain Berg est-ce que on
doit à nouveau garder les transports les
collèges le social dont on dit souvent
que social personne n'en veut parce que
ça coûte cher je pense que tant qu'on
aura pas fait une véritable réforme
territoriale il va être difficile
peut-être aujourd'hui à notre niveau
niveau de décider des compétences que
doivent avoir devrait avoir le Conseil
Général moi je pense que aujourd'hui les
compétences qui sont en place sont des
compétences qui qui sont tout à fait
légitimes et en tout cas qui
fonctionnent très très bien la seule
difficulté aujourd'hui du département
c'est que comme tous les collectivité
nous avons des difficultés de perte de
dotation qui sont importantes et quand
on a une perte de dotation de plus de
140 millions d'euros ne serait-ce que
sur le département il est vrai que c'est
difficile mais en tout cas au niveau du
social c'est une importance capit de le
garder puisque cette compétence a fait
ses preuves et qu'aujourd'hui il est pas
question du tout
d'abandonner j'ai pu le constater lors
des échanges avec les autres candidats
et particulièrement avec le président
donc il faut garder les compétences
actuelles ou patri Charton vous avez
voulez
réagir je pense que que franchement il y
a une répartition à à à conserver comme
celle qui existe aujourd'hui par exemple
pour les les handicapés sur lesquels on
peut agir d'une d'une manière un petit
peu plus plus active par exemple sur le
département on sait qu'aujourd'hui c'est
c'est surtout la gestion de de Dossi de
de demande de de de de prise en charge
alors qu'il y a beaucoup d'autres choses
à faire sur sur sur le territoire ici il
y a des des des tas de choses enfin moi
je suis touchée par ma maman qui qui qui
est handicapée et
qui et qui est pas forcément qui a
peut-être plus bénéficié de la part mais
euh ouis enfin plus plus maintenant mais
euh euh mais c'est vrai que c'est très
difficile l'aide est très très compliqué
à mettre en place et on voit bien que le
discours la la le discours est assez
loin des réalités entre euh les
personnes sont laissées assez euh assez
à leur à leur enfin à la charge de leur
famille quoi Nicolas eu les compétences
oui moi je pense que les compétences du
département telles qu'elles doivent être
discuté enfin tell qu'elles sont
discutées aujourd'hui et tell qu'elles
doivent être euh prorogé par la suite je
pense évidemment que l'action sociale
comme l'éducation
doivent être des liens forts qui doivent
rester au sein du département notamment
pour ce que l'on évoquait tout à l'heure
la question de la proximité je pense que
c'est très important de garder cette
cette notion là mais à condition
évidemment que les départements le
prennent à bras le corps aussi cette ces
notions là moi je prends juste un
exemple vous le rappeliez juste juste à
l'instant sur la question du handicap
quand je vois aujourd'hui que le
département des ivelines est obligé est
obligé parce qu'il ne veut pas le faire
de signer des conv
avec la Belgique pour accueillir nos
personnes en situation de handicap je
trouve que là précisément il y a une
défaillance de notre de notre système et
de notre de notre de la majorité
départementale pour enrayer ce ce ce
fléo de de départ malheureusement qui
coûte cher aux familles c'est la même
chose pour les pour les épades pour les
établissements pour les personnes âgé
dépendantes où aujourd'hui on voit que
que ces ces coûts à la journée sont
relativement chers parce que précisément
le départ des ivelines n'intervient pas
directement et n'intervient pas
fortement sur ces questions là et
lorsqu'on regarde un petit peu aux
alentours dans les départements voisins
on se rend compte que les prix de
journée sont aux alentour de 60 65 € le
département desin n pas fait voilà
renforcer le social mais surtout faire
en sorte que les compétences que le
département aura soi réellement prises à
Brasc par le département et par son
institution et sa
majorité avant même d'évoquer tous ces
sujet des compétences du du futur
conseil
départemental le le but peut-être du
conseiller futur ce sera de sauver le
Conseil départemental ou du moins sauver
euh la structure qui aujourd'hui euh euh
risque de disparaître encore une fois
comme on le disait puisque apparemment
la proximité ça n'est plus d'actualité
qu'on va passer à une politique de
d'hyper région puisque le but finalement
c'est toujours ce ce projet européen qui
est de faire de notre pays une région de
Bruxelles donc je pense qu' est
important et c'est pour ça on en revient
d'ailleurs à ce qu'on disait au tout
début c'estàdire qu'il est important de
se déplacer pour à travers ces élections
départementales faire en sorte qu'on
soit tous ensemble derrière un projet
national un projet qui montre que les
gens aiment vivre ensemble et c'est le
projet du Front national c'est de vivre
ensemble derrière une vraie nationalité
et une vraie fierté de notre pays et ce
qui fait qu'évidemment nous nous ne
sommes pas du tout derrière ces
politiques qui font en sorte que demain
euh tout tout cela va disparaître donc
voà on va parler de tout un tas de de de
sujets mais finalement qui les gérera
demain aujourd'hui il y a rien de plus
sûr donc euh il faut s'assurer de ces
politiques futures et et voir un peu
comment on peut les contrer et donc
c'est important de placer des des
conseillers départementaux Fond national
parce que eux ils vont défendre ils vont
défendre réellement euh notre notre
structure aujourd'hui telle qu'on la
connaît ancienne et qui fonctionne
département canton commune et cetera
Fabien oui le historiquement en fait le
département faut rappeler qu'il a été
créé durant la Révolution française afin
de rapprocher les administrés avec les
administrateurs enfin les
administrateurs avec les administrés et
c'est devenu au fil du temps vraiment un
acteur clé du du gouvernement de l'État
et c'est aussi un
acteur social de de premier rang
puisqu'il permet de réduire les
inégalités tant au niveau du territoire
entre territoires riches et territoires
pauvres contre les citoyens afin de don
à chacun les mêmes chances c'est pour ça
que nous nous à debout la France nous
souhaitons faire du département un
acteur clé de l'État l'un des pilier
même de de l'État au même titre que la
commune et que l'État nation donc nous
sommes tout à fait pour la la sauvegarde
de du département et nous souhaitons que
bien sûr que le département garde ses
compétces comp ben on sou que le
département garde ses compéttences voilà
exactement qui garde les mêmes
compétences
d'accord je vais faire une synthèse par
rapport à tout ça parce que bon sur le
principe il y a plein de choses m été
dit c'est bien c'est j'ai l'impression
que c'est un inventaire l' prèvert mais
sur le principe il y a un point qui est
extrêmement important le département
c'est quand même un bouclier social faut
pas l'oublier ces périodes d'austérité
de crise aujourd'hui le rôle du
département il n'est même pas à revoir
ou à rediscuter quand on parlait
notamment vous parliz d'êtes social vous
parliez d'action sociale effectivement
c'est l'une des priorités d'un
département bien évidemment il y a
l'éducatif et autres mais aujourd'hui
c'est ça c'est no anciens c'est les
enfants c'est toutes ces choses-là je
prends un exemple on parlait des pades
tout à l'heure on est quand même dans un
département l'un des départements les
plus riches de France si ce n'est allez
il est dans le Ploton de tête euh au
niveau des crèches par exemple au niveau
des épades il y a quasiment aucune
aucune épade aucune crèche qui est
départemental je prends un exemple par
exemple dans le 94 dans Leah
complètement complètement sur le fond
parce que c'est du bon sens et et ma
voisine était en train d'en parler aussi
je je je rejoins parce que les anciens C
extrêmement important ils ont uvré ils
ont uvré à ce que notre société soit
celle qu'elle est aujourd'hui et et que
l'on puisse en bénéficier de bénéficier
tout le tout ce cet investissement mais
c'est de dire aussi euh faut quand même
y penser et aujourd'hui quand on prend
le valde Marar le valdearne il y a des
crèches qui sont départementales et oui
nous n'en avons aucune dans les ivelines
ce sont que des crèches donc au niveau
des compétences bah par exemple l'enfant
c'est ce que je vous disais l'aide
social l'enfance et autres ça fait
partie véritablement du du du cœur d'Ain
pourquoi parce que proximité oblige bien
évidemment d'accord on va faire une
petite pause dans cette émission on va à
la rencontre des des habitants pour le
aller leur demander ce qu'ils
attendaient d'un conseiller général on
les
écoute des réseaux pour que Ben que les
gens diplômés moins diplômés
puisse être réinséré socialement moi
c'est notamment au niveau de l'école de
l'éducation peut-être plus d'aménagement
au niveau la sécurité
euh des écoles donc notamment bah les
vigiles parce que là on a en période
vigil pirate non ce serait bien qui qui
travaill
là-dessus des écoles des collèges ils
font des travaux en ce moment sur la D30
là il la double
donc c'est quand même une avancée le
problème c'est que là apparemment ils
sont en train de tout changer alors ils
vous disent que les départements vont
quand même continuer les collèges parce
que c'est les routes l'autre c'est après
la grand le grand truc bon ça va être
non le transport enfin c'est c'est
n'importe quoi je veux dire on sait plus
où on en est non je comprends pas on va
continuer à parler évidemment des des
élections départemental sur le canton de
de plaisir on va s'intéresser maintenant
à trois thématiques qui sont le le
développement économique l'emploi
environnement et puis on parlera
également évidemment du du social qui
vous préoccupe on l'a bien compris
autour de cette table alors d'abord le
l'emploi et le développement économique
on en parle parce que c'est une zone
évidemment le canton de plaisir qui
compte qui comprend beaucoup de de
centres commerciaux on va commencer avec
vous jeisine Colman berger parce que
vous avez du temps de retard qu'est-ce
que vous proposez en matière de de
développement économique sur ce canton
mais le développement économique
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
doit être en lien direct avec les
collectivités aujourd'hui puisque les
collectivités sont des acteurs premiers
et le département une un regard aussi
par rapport à ça aujourd'hui on peut pas
dire que sur la zone qui sont qui est le
canton aujourd'hui de de plaisir est un
Grandon en grande difficulté puisque a
beaucoup de centres commerciaux il y a
éormément de centres commerciaux et le
taux de chômage est quand même assez bas
donc c'est vrai que c'est il y a encore
énormément de choses à faire mais il est
vrai que ne serait-ce que tout ce qui
est la fibre actuellement qui est en
cours d'installation sur la collectivité
les collectivités qui sont autour on il
est important que le département c'est
ce qu'il est en train de faire soit en
développement important pour les
entreprises parce que c'est une attente
aujourd'hui par rapport à cela et il est
clair que aujourd'hui nous devons
absolument au niveau du département
développer cela au niveau du rural et
dans ce canton il y a toute une partie
rurale qui l'attend et il est important
que le le responsable qui sera en place
politiquement parlant et bien puisse
avoir ce regard là il est important
aussi d'accompagner les jeunes au niveau
de l'emploi euh tout tout ça est déjà en
cours j'entends entendais tout à l'heure
tous les reproches qu'on pouvait faire
au département de des ivelines et au
conseil général je peux dire que c'est
pas si noir que ça bien au contraire il
y a des actions très fortes qui sont
faites au niveau du social il y a eu une
augmentation de 3,6 au niveau du RSA et
les accompagnements sont forts et les
développements au niveau des crèches je
reviens un tout petit peu en arrière si
vous le permettez et au niveau des
éepades est une véritable volonté au qui
pas partagé par non je le sais mais
c'est non bien sûr non non mais les
chiffres sont là ce que je disais que
c'est un développement à faire et qui
est tout à fait oui mais parlons pas de
de ce qui est passé parlons de l'avenir
et de ce qu'il faut mettre en place et
je sais qu'aujourd'hui c'est une
véritable volonté du département malgré
les baisses et les dotations dont je
parlais tout à l'heure parce qu'il faut
quand même en tenir compte et je sais
que toute la la vérité qui qui est
aujourd'hui celle du département est
quand même un département qualitatif et
un département qui fonctionne bien et je
pense que les personnes qui l'avaient
entre les mains jusqu'à présent ça
fonction c'est la réponse candidat de de
l'UMP au au candidat du P faen m alors
pour le développement
économique nous avons trois mesures
trois mesures choc pour le développement
économique la première c'est de
relocaliser l'argent qui investit qui
sert à des invvestissements à l'étranger
faut savoir que depuis 2006 c'est près
de 8 millions d'euros qui ont été
investis à l'étranger cet argent là on
souhaiterait qu'il soit utilisé pour
pour les illunois euh deuxième chose
nous souhaitons réduire les frais de
frais des élus un élu coûte en moyenne
50000 € par an c'est relativement
excessif surtout lorsqu'on sait que
beaucoup d'élus demande au au
concitoyens de faire des efforts je
pense que la moindre des choses c'est de
montrer soi-même l'exemple et enfin nous
souhaitons développer les circuit court
montrer l'exemple c'est réduire voilà de
réduire alors serait de l'ordre de 1000
€ sur 1000 € ce serait réduire les les
frais de séminaire les frais de
formation et tout ça c'est normal qu'un
élu soit payé c'est qui qu'il a une
indemnité mais il y a quand même enfin
je pense qu'il y a quand même une
dessence à avoir surtout en période de
crise ensuite nous voulons développer
les circuits courts euh la les ibines
ont la chance de d'être un territoire
avec un Milu rural très riche et aussi
des beaucoup de villes pour pour trouver
des consommateurs et ce circuit Cour
aurait quatre avantage majeur c'est dans
dans l'ordre économique ça créit des
emplois de l'ordre social ça me permet
aux producteurs d'être payé
convenablement de l'ordre écologique
parce qu'en réduisant les les transports
on réduit les le l'impact énergétique et
les gaz à effet de serre
et voilà
chon Fabien met parle de circuit court
forcément ça doit vous parler à vous des
thèmes du fondement même de bon après il
y a pas il y a pas que les circuit
courts circuit court c'est vraiment
essentiel pour apporter aussi un un lien
social je sais pas si vous vous achetez
vos légumes che dans une AMAP ou moi
c'est ce que je fais euh pour
justement supporter ces ces ces
producteurs locaux je fais mon marché
tous les tous les weekend chez tous les
producteurs locaux et et et les gens ne
savent pas forcément qu'il existe tous
ces producteurs donc là aussi il y a
quelque chose à faire exactement il y a
quelque chose à faire pour les aider
pour promouvoir évidemment installation
de nouveaux maréchers parce que là le
maréchage en effet qu'il soit bio alors
moi je suis plutôt bio évidemment parce
que c'est c'est c'est ça va évidemment
dans le dans le dans le sens du
développement durable ce qui est pas du
tout le cas de de la culture intensive
aujourd'hui nous sommes entourés de
céréaliers qui qui font du colsa pour
pour les les pour les carburants qui
font bon c'est c'est c'est c'est pas
avec ça qu'on peut se nourrir hein donc
donc voilà le circuit court certain mais
pas mais pas que il y a évidemment
beaucoup d'autres choses à faire au
niveau au niveau développement durable
et et et dans le développement durable
l'énergie peut apporter aussi énormément
d'emplois voilà c'est c'esténergie
comment énergies les énergies
renouvelables on sait on sait que les
les le photovoltaïque a énormément
progressé on on a entendu ce matin le le
lancement d'un d'un avion qui qui ne
fonctionne qu'au solaire donc c'est tout
tout à fait réalisable on peut réaliser
ça à un niveau on sait qu'on a on a très
bien progressé dans ce dans ce domaine
là et et on sait que les ressources
aujourd'hui sont plus sont en diminution
on est arrivé à un pic un pic et les les
Chinois absorbent ce qui ce qu'il en
reste donc les Chinois les en donc le
circuit court évidemment évidemment
c'est c'est c'est le salut c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment le salut Nicola
le développement économique l'emploi
ouais moi j'essaierai de rebondir très
rapidement ement sur ce que sur ce que
annonçait madame colmansberger tout à
l'heure euh sur la question économique
alors évidemment il y a une for zone
forte zone pardon de densité commerciale
sur le sur le secteur plaisir les Clais
mais ce que je regrette moi pour pour le
coup c'est que nous n'ayons pas une
diversité d'offres en terme de
d'entreprise et notamment d'offre
d'entreprise industriell je sais que
nous avons sur le secteur plaisir les
clés donc plus sur les clés situé sur
les clés mais qui aurait pu aussi être à
un moment donné vecteur d'emploi sur
l'ensemble du bassin nous avons le
l'entreprise Bull qui étaé racheté ces
derniers temps par Athos il y a quelques
mois et cette entreprise est le leader
européen avec Athos désormais leader
européen dans le développement
informatique et je pense qu'il aurait
été de bon ton de développer sur le
territoire de notre commune au clés
sous-bois de notre intercommunalité et
du département tout un maillage autour
de ce cette de cette entreprise de
recherche et de développement qui aurait
permis qui peut permettre alors j'espère
que rien n'est définitif et on peut
toujours intervenir et qui permettrait
justement de présenter des emplois
qualifiés et des emplois pérennes parce
qu'aujourd'hui le problème des emplois
dit commerciaux c'est évidemment leur
précarité enfin je connais peu de
personnes qui travaillent dans le
aujourd'hui dans la distribution et qui
ont un 35 heur au bout du compte on sait
que ce sont avant tout des emplois pour
les jeunes ou les jeunes étudiants sur
rapidement sur les sur les sur la la
fibre optique je j'entendais madame
colmberger par rappeler que la fibre
optique était était importante à
déployer notamment en terre rurale je
voudrais enfin moi je ne peux que la
rejoindre là-dessus euh tout en sachant
que lorsque le président Bédier est
revenu au au manettes du conseil général
il y a un an un an et demi il a arrêté
ce plan de développement euh pour quelle
raison je n'en sais trop rien mais en
tout cas le plan de déploiement de fibre
optique a été arrêté par le président en
place donc aujourd'hui enfin je trouve
ça très bien que il y ait des effets
d'annonce pendant la campagne j'espère
juste qu'ils seront suivis et en tout
cas nous nous nous appliquerons si nous
sommes élus évidemment à le mettre en
place euh et puis dernière chose sur la
question la question économique par que
vous allez prendre de l'avant sur le
temp vot d'accord je reprendrai après
d'accord Éric Gigou alors vous avez non
et on va voir les temps de paroles qui
vont s'afficher d'ailleurs donc en fait
c'estra qu'en écoutant un petit peu tout
le monde je m'aperçois que tout le monde
a un petit peu le le même programme
concernant le le département et c'est
pour ça que à un moment donné je pense
qu'il faut un peu prendre de hauteur
toujours pour euh voir quel principe on
peut appliquer par rapport à l'hyper
région qui pourrait
nous le futur le futur projet puisque
vous appartenez à des partis qui ont eu
le le le le pouvoir entre les mains ou
qui qui l'ont et donc euh je pense qu'il
faut à un moment donné sortir de ça pour
avoir une
une nouvelle vue un nouvel angle et
attaquer les choses autrement vous par
exemple votre parti en terme de
développement économique sur ce canton
vous proposez quoi bah déjà ce qu'il
faudrait c'est encourager les
entreprises à rester en France et encore
une fois ça aussi ça ça alors sur le
canton ou sur le canton évidemment mais
ça fait partie d'une politique générale
et donc effectivement moi dans mon
travail je rencontre pas mal
d'entreprises et les chefs d'entreprise
me le disent si aujourd'hui ils
pouvaient si c'était à refaire peut-être
ils iraient créer entreprise ailleurs
donc encore une fois ça participe d'un
d'un principe fort d'appartenance à
notre nation et encore une fois c'est
vraiment le vivre ensemble qui fera que
à un moment donné les gens auront envie
de se battre pour notre pays et qu'
qu'on soit ensemble et et qu'on aille
pas vers des projets qui nous échappent
et c'est pour ça que les départemental
c'est important euh pour revenir à ce
qu'on dit au début de d'y
participer pour contrer t tous ces
futurs projets qui sont les mêmes de des
des différents partis UMP ou PS
finalement puisque là encore une fois on
parle de sujet mais au-delà de ça le la
finalité c'est que c'est ces partis on
sont sont sont se sont engagés dans une
autre voie et une voie qui nous échappe
donc il faut rattraper ça euh en en se
se restant tous derrière un pays qui est
le nôtre qui est un grand pays et qu'on
peut pas laisser échapper donc vous avez
une vision plusob que purement voilà
exactement plus large mais oui tout est
lié est c'est sûr jamti alors oui sur
sur la partie emploi effectivement
plutôt favoriser l'emploi cons la France
excusez-moi merci aujourd'hui nous
votons pour les les conseils
départementaux nous allons voter pour
les conseils départementaux on vous
laisse débattre après sur le principe
sur le principe effectivement sur
l'emploi la politique de l'emploi
effectivement aider plutôt les
entreprises les PME et autres et non pas
aider les grands groupes qui vont se
répartir les les les résultats
financiers de leur de leur recettes
auprès de leurs différents actionnaires
donc ça c'est ça c'est une politique
forte plutôt que d'aller aider les
sociétés qui n'en ont pas forcément
besoin qui viennent juste chercher des
subventions c'est peut-être ça la vraie
politique au niveau de l'emploi et
favoriser l'implantation des entreprises
dans notre canton notamment et on parle
sur un point effectivement notre canton
est quand même assez marqué par par
l'emploi on va dire dans de la
distribution alors je rejoins
complètement la vie de de de mon voisin
sur le principe effectivement c'est un
emploi précaire par nature et là
aujourd'hui on a des certaines communes
ont voté sur la possibilité de
travailler le dimanche c'est quand même
pas mal ça comme truc et là on parle
d'une approche sociale et moi dans
l'approche sociale quand même un point
important c'est ok pour travailler le
dimanche mais ces gens-l ont peut-être
des enfants comment on fait pour le pour
que les enfants a en crèche il y a pas
de crèche ouverte le dimanche et en plus
si j'en rajoute encore une petite couche
c'est que ces gens-là vont travailler le
dimanche mais sans avoir une majoration
de leur salaire donc travailler plus
pour gagner plus je crois que c'est un
vieux slogan mais qui est vraiment usé
alors élimé donc sur le principe oui
effectivement l'emploi arrêtons de
favoriser de faire ces méga centres
commerciaux ça pourrait être intéressant
et développons le travail les centres
commerciaux il y en a il y en a
c'est pour ça ce serait peut-être bien
d'arrêter pour ça je vous le dis en
synthèse et peut-être plutôt favoriser
l'implantation d'entreprise de PME par
le biais de pépinir d'entreprise etid
véritablement les entreprises de moins
de 10 ou 15 salariés qui elles sont
vraiment génératrices d'emploi donc est
plutôt les petites entreprises on va
continuer à parler évidemment des du
quanton de de plaisir on va jeter aussi
un coup d'œil sur les les temps de
paroles qui vont s'afficher je vrais
maintenant qu'on parle de de
l'environnement du cadre de vie et puis
évidemment de de l'aménagement VO les
temp de paroles qui s'affichent de
l'aménagement de de la r RD30 c'est
éidemment les travaux ont
démarré alors sur l'environnement le
cadre de vie Fabian met et la RD30 si
vous avez alors sur la r 30 nous nous on
est plutôt d'accord c'est faut faut être
honnête c'est c'est une bonne chose ça
permet de fidifier la
circulation de limiter les bouchons
parce que faut savoir que l' RD30 était
saturé que ce soit en semaine ou le
weekend aux hor de pointe et le weekend
lorsque les gens allaient aller faire
leurs courses en centrreville ou ou dans
les centres commerciaux et et les
travaux sont lancés donc de toute façon
on riendra pasra pas en arrière c'est
pour dire qu'on est on faut être honnête
on est plutôt on est plutôt d'accord
surtout voilà il y a aussi y a aussi un
problème de de pollution qui avait eu
enfin qui a avec les bouchons qui aura
plus une fois que les travaux seront
terminés donc nous on est plutôt
favorable à ces travaux là lorsqu'ils
sont fait lorsqu'ils peuvent être faits
par le Département ce que c'est vrai que
le contexte est difficile et sur
l'environnement le cadre de vie pour le
canton bah qu'est-ce qui doit être
préservé selon vous qu'est-ce qui doit
être développé bah il y a sur enfin il y
a une il y a une départementale la
départementale 191 qui malheureusement
connaî ce que connaî actuellement à RD30
mais qui a qui a pas eu la chance
d'avoir les travaux nécessaires donc on
aimerait bien dans la mesure du possible
faire des travaux pour désengorger cette
voie là qui est comme les RD30 saturé le
en semaine essentiellement pendant les
ordes de
pointeg je vais pas vous faire de
commentaires sur la RD30 vous imaginez
bien bien que en tant maire de plaisir
voilà et puis avec un investissement de
79 millions d'euros de la part du
département ça ne peut être que bien
accueilli j'imagine c'est attendu depuis
20 ans outre outre tout cela pour le
cadre de vie il faut reconnaître que ces
derniers temps nous avons des
accompagnements très forts de la part du
département ne serait-ce que sur
certaines départementales qui viennent
de se construire la rt98 qui facilite
quand même la circulation entre plaisir
lesclés Villepreux et puis d'autre part
toutes tous les rond-points qui qui ont
pris corps
au sein de de nos diverses collectivités
il y a aussi des demandes qui sont en
cours comme des rond-points au clés
sous-bois pas des rond-points mais des
pardon des souterrain ou clés sous-bois
qui sont demandés pour aller plus
facilement à la gare il y a des projets
très importants au niveau de
l'environnement puisque on souhaite
faire tout un respect par rapport aux
zones agricoles qui sont fondamentales
pour nous vous le disiez en propos
liminire aujourd'hui nous avons la
chance d'avoir un territoire qui est
dans un équilibre rural urbain que nous
souhaitons maintenir bien évidemment
ment même avec l'intégration dans la
casquie même si c'est hors sujet mais
pas tant que ça puisque le département
est également un rempart de de de
respect de tout cet environnement là
donc on aura je dirais un regard très
particulier par rapport à ce maintien de
ce rural urbain qui fait notre qualité
et qui est la caractéristique première
de notre département et effectivement
cet accompagnement qui est omniprésent
de la part du département chaque fois
qu'il y a une demande spécifique par
exemple d'un rond-point d'une am
amélioration je pourrais vous donner des
détails qui sont des détails qui sont
entre les clés et plaisir sur des
rond-points qui vont avoir et faciliter
la circulation entre nos zones
commerciales et qui vont permettre après
la mise en place de la RD30 d'une
fluidité beaucoup plus importante donc
ça c'est le cadre de vie fondamental et
le le département sera et est déjà mais
sera encore plus présent par la suite
Nicol sur le vous êtes cléien lorsque
dit
moi ce qui m'interpelle le plus sur le
sur les clés sous-bois euh et notamment
au niveau des routes c'est évidemment la
sécurisation de certaines routes
notamment la RD11 qui aujourd'hui n'est
absolument pas sécurisée euh lorsque
enfin voilà c'est pas la 98 alors non
mais je parlais aussi de la RD1 avec un
nouveau rond-point préparé par le
Conseil Général d'accord moi je parle ou
moi je ne parle pas uniquement des des
rond-points qui sont des des des des
comment dire des aménagements qui
servent essentiellement les les véhicule
moi je pense aussi qu'il faut penser au
piéton et aux voies douces aujourd'hui
il n'y a rien de prévu autour de des
grands centres commerciaux qui ont été
réalisés ils ne sont pas arrivés ils ne
sont toujours pas là et en tout cas il
n'y a pas de d'endroit de passage
notamment pour les jeunes collégiens qui
se rendent du quartier Nord desclés
sous-bois par exemple au collège Anatole
France il n'y a pas d'aménagement
spécifique permettant de sécuriser leur
leur leur comment dire le l'accès de
l'un l'autre côté de de la rue et de la
même manière lorsque vous êtes d'un d'un
côté des centres commerciaux il n'y a
pas d'accès pour enfin sécurisé pour les
piétons pour passer d'un centre
commercial à l'autre donc il y a toute
une partie de sécurisation de de de cet
aménagement de cette route
départementale je pense à revoir sur la
RD30 parce que c'est quand même un sujet
important la RD30 maintenant est lancé
enfin évidemment personne va revenir en
arrière ce serait complètement
stupide le seul la seule question qu'on
peut qu'on peut se poser c'est c'est
quand même avant tout le le les
nombreuses remarques qui ont été posées
lors de l'enquête publique en 2007 qui
n'ont pas été qui n'ont pas été
forcément suivi des faits c'estd qu'il y
a eu de nombreuses remarques faite à
l'époque lors de l'enquête d'utilité
publique par les riverins il y a eu plus
de 800 ou 1000 riverins qui ont quand
même porté leur une remarque lors des de
cette enquête et les principales était
quand même d'assurer la continuité la
circulation douce notamment et sécuriser
l'abord de la circulation douce au
nouveau au niveau du rond-point du petit
saint-clou aujourd'hui il n'y a rien de
prévu de je fa JG dit si si c'est prévu
les choses sont prévues mais c'est c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être prévu mais
c'est en tout cas pas présenté ainsi et
je trouve que c'est dommage de ne pas le
présenter ou de ne pas l'avoir prévu au
préalable sachant que c'est un
aménagement qui coûte 78 millions
d'euros 78 millions d'euros de 2005
revalorisé aujourd'hui avec les indices
de travaux et cetera à 96 millions donc
c'est un un un investissement très fort
et que je trouve dommage je trouve
dommage de ne pas avoir tout prévu dès
le départ et notamment c'est circul donc
donc on n pas fait assez par je vous
écout le principal c'est que ce soit
fait soit fait pas Charton sur
l'environnement le cadre de vie on pas
revenir sur l'erg laire détente mais
est-ce qu'on peut faire plus que pr pas
que la détente c'est vrai que les
travaux sont lancés de de toute façon
donc a des des des voies des voies
cyclables qui sont qui sont prévu je les
ai vu sur le sur le plan mais il y a pas
que la RD30 parce que je connais peu de
gens qui vont faire leur courses depuis
les gaâtines jusque jusqu'à auchamp à
vélo ou à pied donc c'est bien pour les
promeneurs mais moi ce que j'aurais aimé
aussi c'est que dans le département on a
une vision un petit peu moins tout
voiture
euh et qu'on puisse aller vers par
exemple la possibilité de financer des
euh le le vélo électrique par exemple
pour les gens qui veulent partir à vélo
jusqu'à leur gare aujourd'hui c'est un
peu scabreux euh il y a pas grandchose
il faut monter sur le trottoir ou
risquer de se faire enverser sur la sur
la voie publique pour pouvoir accéder au
garees on a rien pour poser son vélo
enfin c'est c'est ce ce genre de truc on
voit pas assez d'équipement en tout cas
plus d'équipement voilà on voit pas
grandchose des villes ont réellement
développé ce genre de de de
d'aménagement de pouvoir déposer dans un
endroit sécurisé son son son de roues
euh et et et ça c'est quelque chose qui
je pense serait serait un réel plus euh
pour les les personnes qui n'ont plus
envie de polluer qui n'ont pas les
moyens de de de s'acheter un véhicule
motorisé et qui qui on a un petit peu
assez d'être complètement pressurisé
dans les dans les transports en commun
bon c'est c'est c'est c'est une voie
possible Éric Gigou je pense qu'on est
tous pour un aménagement des routes des
choses qui ne polluent pas maintenant
tout ça c'est un coup donc il faut bon
moi je suis pas au conseil général et
pas élu donc j'ai pas les dossiers ou du
moins le chiffrage de ces dossiers là
donc après tout ça ça se ça se calcule
et ça en fonction des possibilités aussi
de à la fois d'aménagement et et de
financement c'est d' rien de plus sur le
l'environnement allezy parce que vous
avez pas mal d'avance vous avez pas mal
de retard pardon sur votre par par
rapport à l'environnement voilà la
circulation c'est un problème de de
financement pour vous c'est aussi aussi
un problème de financement et encore une
fois là on parle peut-être peêtre d'une
coqu vite puisque encore une fois je
reviens il encore je reviens encore à la
charge là-dessus c'est on ne sait pas on
ne sait pas encore
aujourd'hui qui va décider de tout ça
donc moi ce qui m'intéresse faire des
propositions on peut toujours faire des
propositions mais sinon ça va pas
vraiment donner envie aux électeurs
d'aller voter si on leur dit on va pas
connaître les les compétences et du coup
mais oui mais enfin faut bien défendre
ce qui nous permet aujourd'hui de de de
de faire toutes ces actions et
apparemment tout ça c'est amené à
changer voir à disparaître pour d'autres
choses donc oui on peut toujours faire
des propositions mais encore une fois il
faut les tenir donc ça sert à rien de
faire des propositions si on si elles ne
sont pas tenues ou si on ne sait pas
d'ici l'horizon 2020 ce qui va se passer
j que vous avez des propositions vous à
faire je suis pas teneur d'un catalogue
miraculeux hein moi je me présente tout
simplement pour porter une idée et une
une image qui est plutôt celle de le de
l'anti de l'anti austérité et compagnie
déjà donc je suis pas là pour donner un
catalogue qui ne sera une fois les les
les les élections passé complètement
mieux oubliett donc moi un constat très
simple on parle notamment de la
casquille on parle du département on
parle de la ville la ville nouvelle de
plaisir et compagnie exemple tout bête
je sais pas si ça vous arrive moi ça
m'arrive d'aller à la base de loiser de
Saint-Quentin en vélo ben je vous mets
au défi d'y aller c'est tout donc je
vais pas plus loin donc effectivement
tout est fait pour la voiture dans notre
canton vous habitez ben pour venir à
plaisir vous prenez le bus de temps en
temps le train quand il y en a le
weekend je vous en parle pas le bus
certains hires voilà c'est ce que je
sous entendais effectivement idem pour
le train donc voilà donc effectivement
arrêtons de faire du tout voiture alors
je vous parle pas non plus de nos zones
commerciales tout voiture mais ça veut
dire quoi développer les pistes au cycl
dév la circulation douce jeux dire
toutes les toutes les alternatives
possibles pour éviter déjà la pollution
on parle l'environnement on parle aussi
de facilité pour nos concitoyens se
déplacer tout le monde n'a pas de
voiture tout le monde n'a pas de permis
donc c'est ça aussi le gros problème
donc aujourd'hui moi j'ai l'impression
que c'est du tout voiture effectivement
et pour revenir à l'IR des 30 moi je
reste sceptique et je reste toujours à
l'écoute sur un sujet très simple moi
j'aimerais bien connaître le plan
réellement la transparence au niveau des
projets autoroutiers dans les Yvelines
parce que le projet de RD30 en lui-même
qui n'a pas donné accès à tous les à
tous les quartiers donc qui a vraiment
donné place à une autoroute dans notre
dans la ville de plaisir et des clés qui
a séparé nos deux villes moi je serais
curieux de savoir quelle est la vraiment
la teneur de ce projet à terme parce
qu'on nous a toujours tenu éloigné et je
rejoins l' vie de de certains qui
consistaent à dire oui en 2007 des
remarques et des propositions étaient
faites elles sont laissé letttre mortte
personne ne les a suivi personne ne les
a écouté c'est un peu triste parce que
les Plaisirois et l'écléiens avaient
leur Moot à dire sur le sujet voilà
Fabien met oui ben de toute façon on est
je pense qu'on est plus d'accord on veut
plus de plus d'énergie verte plus de
ceci plus de cela mais je pense que faut
malgré le fait qu'on soit actuellement
tous dans l'opposition faut quand même
être réaliste et et prendre conscience
que le département n ne roule pas sur
l'or on a pas encore découvert de
pétrole dans les ulines faut
euh pourtant on a cherché on a on a
beaucoup creusé sur T en ce moment à
plaisir dans un département riche je c
ou sous sous le sous le territoire
découv l'écologie he mais bon on est
dans un département riche avec des
priorités qui sont tout oui oui non mais
il y a quandme des réalités qu'il faut
prendre en compte et bien sûr nous à
Debou la France on est on est aussi pour
plus d'écologie pour sécuriser les
transports et tout ça mais faut quand
même faut quand même être réaliste
quoi faut être ah bah vous avez le même
discours qu'ou faut faut être sur les
moyens pourant vous êtes alors va
changer de plaisir ou on va changer de
sujet peut-être que vous aurez peut-être
plus de choses à dire on va parler du du
du social de la petite pe enfance des
logements du personne handicapé alors
Fabien je vous repasse la parole en
matière de de social alors vous êtes
plutôt vous vous dites il faut combattre
la fraude sociale c'est un V point de ah
non en fait on c'est pas tout à fait ça
en fait on beaucoup de personnes on
n'ont pas accès aux aides parce qu'en
fait elles ont elles ont pas conscience
qu' qu'elles peuvent en accéder aux aid
donc nous en fait on est pour
rééquilibrer en fait les aides parce que
en effet il y a certaines personnes qui
en abusent d'un côté et d'autres
personnes qui pourraient en profiter
mais qui qui osent pas ou qui euh qui ne
sont pas suffisamment informés pour en
bénéficier donc en fait on cherche à à
faire en sorte qu'il y a un
rééquilibrage entre et les deux mais
nous vons nous traquons pas non les nous
traquons pas les gens nous nous vouons
juste un rééquilibrage des aides
d'accord et sur d'autres sur le social
plus largement sur le social plus
largement petit enfance on en a un petit
peu parlé la problématique des des
crèches des épades oui voilà justement
bah pour parlant des crèches justement
euh nous souhaitons soutenir les
associations qui ouvrent des places de
crèche euh parce que c'est vrai que dans
les ibines on manque de place de crèche
aussi pour les pour les personnes
handicapées surtout enfin pour les
enfants en situation de handicap nous
souhaitons embaucher des des auxilires
de vie scolaire afin de permettre à ces
enfants de de profiter comme tous les
tous les autres enfants tous les jees
enfants et vulois de des collèges d'être
il y a pas de raison qu'il soit mis à
l'écart ils sont pas ils sont comme nous
surtout que ça permettrait aussi
d'humaniser un peu le les col égen et de
de se rendre compte de la chance que
qu'on peut avoir d'être en bonne santé
et enfin nous souhaitons mettre en
lumière un problème qui est pas assez
connu à notre goût c'est la maltraitance
des des personnes retraitées on parle
surtout de maltraitance passive de
personnel de de maison de retraite qui
étant donné qu'elles sont sous infectif
en fait ont tendance à à
involontairement maltraiter les
personnes âgées donc nous souhaitons
embucher du personnel pour les maisons
de retraite afin de d'éviter ce genre de
problème donc plus de de personnel
notamment dans les maisons de retraite
c'est ça Éric Gigou au niveau du social
est-ce que vous avez des propositions et
bien par que là c'est une compétence du
conseil général que certainement Conseil
général va va conserver va conserver oui
effectivement B on parlait de de fraude
tout à l'heure et il me semble qu'il y a
10 % des fraudes seulement qui sont
détectés au niveau du RSA donc c'est
vrai que ce serait bien de mettre en
place des outils qui permettent de de
contrôler un petit mieux un petit peu
mieux tout ça de façon à reverser euh
par exemple à d'autres à d'autres choses
comme Lapa ou ou d'autres systèmes comme
ceuxla
euh concernant le handicap évidemment
mettre des choses en place moi je vais
apprendre un peu ce que disait monsieur
met mais l'accès aux établissements et
ce tout ça c'est très important et
l'accompagnement aussi des personnes
handicapées euh ou même le le la
possibilité de financer ou d'aider les
entreprises par exemple pour l'accès
certains niveau de handicap moi j'ai
connu une entreprise qui a fait mettre
en place un certain type de système
parce qu'elle avait un salarié qui avait
eu un accident grave et je pense qu'elle
a pas été aidée par exemple cette cette
société là donc peut-être mettre en
place des choses pour aider l'entreprise
de façon à accueillir son salarié donc
soutenir un peu plus les entreprises
notamment dans le milieu du si elle
reste en France parce qu'elles ont
tendance à partir les entreprises
oui un peu d'Hour ah d'accord on va on
va regarder vos vos temps de parole
dans quelques instants et Joséphine
Colman berger et Patricia Charton vous
avez un peu de retard sur vos camarades
autour de la table donc Jos je vous
passz la parole sur toute la partie
sociale peti enfance personne en
situation de handicap ou encore logement
qu'est-ce que le conseil général peut
faire d'autres sachant que c'est une une
compétence qui est importante bien sûr
c'est fondamental même puisque la
population même si elle reste jeune au
niveau du département est quand même
vieillissante donc on a un véritable
souci d' agnement aujourd'hui on peut
pas dire que le département je vous
disais tout à l'heure ne soit pas dans
cette compétence mais il est certain que
il va falloir certainement avoir un
regard beaucoup plus précis par rapport
aux accompagnements parce qu'il doit y
avoir certainement on s'en est rendu
compte des personnes qui ne sont pas
suffisamment accompagné et d'autres qui
le sont peut-être pas du tout
parce ça revient à ce que disait
effectivement monsieur met il est clair
aussi que au niveau des crèches
aujourd'hui on a un vrai manque au
niveau des crèches donc il y a toute une
action d'accompagnement qui doit être
faite euh au niveau des collectivités
par rapport par le biais de subvention
et puis aussi par rapport aux
microocèches privées qui sont en train
de fleurir sur les sur les villes et on
s'en rend compte et on on ne peut en
être je dirais que satisfait à ce
niveau-là il est vrai que la santé est
un véritable souci également avec les
PMI il est vrai que les PMI doivent être
maintenu développé c'est une véritable
aide au niveau de au niveau des
collectivités par rapport à la petite
enfance par rapport au suivi des
familles euh par rapport à toutes toutes
toutes tous ces enfants qui qui
effectivement ont besoin d'une d'une pas
d'une compétence mais d'une
reconnaissance et d'un accompagnement de
compétenence de certaines personnes
quand les familles ne peuvent pas le
faire au niveau des personnes âgées pour
les épades il est clair que on a un
manque mais parce que je le disais tout
à l'heure il est clair que la la
population est en vieillissante il est
il faut un accompagnement mais pas
uniquement je dirais au niveau des
épades mais également au niveau des
constructions qui peuvent être faites
dans les collectivité sur des résidences
qui sont des résidences que nous on
imagine très intergénérationnell où on
pourrait faire des mélanges entre les
personnes âgées et les plus jeunes il y
a déj d'ailleurs un projet comme
celui-là à plaisir au niveau de la
l'ancienne gendarmerie qui a été reprise
par la par les par les pilles justement
du conseil général et qui nous
accompagne dans ce projet donc tout ça
ce sont des vrais démarche et sans
vouloir faire de pont euh marche arrière
par rapport à ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure mais il est clair qu'il y a
énormément de choses qui sont déjà en
cours et quand vous parliez de euh de
d'énergie verte quand vous parliez
d'environnement de circulation 12 il
faut savoir ce que fait le département
et je crois qu'il y a des choses que
peut-être vous ne connaissez pas
suffisamment et qui sont déjà très en
cours sans vouloir dire autre chose
Charton je posse la parole alors je
pense qu' pas mieux informé parce que
oui moi je sais que j'ai j'ai lu j'ai lu
t t sur le sur le plateau de télfil vous
découvrez les choses sur le social
Patricia char donc sur le sur le social
ce que je pense c'est qu'en fait on
travaille au niveau départemental ou
communal sur une prise en charge des les
personnes qui qui qui en ont le plus
besoin mais ce qui me semble vraiment
essentiel aussi c'est de recréer du lien
social et et ça on peut pas le faire par
des structures
euh départementales ou communal je pense
qu'on ça doit venir du citoyen et pour
moi ça vient essentiellement du monde
associatif je travaille moi dans enfin
pour une association surbaine qui permet
de de développer par exemple le le
logement
intergénérationnel c'est quelque chose
qui est pas forcément facile à mettre en
place et les communes ne sont pas
forcément toujours très actives sur sur
sur ce type de sujet on a beaucoup
d'autres au niveau au niveau de de ces
associations beaucoup d'autres projets
qui permettent justement ce lien social
et plus on a du lien social et plus on
on on on est proche les uns des autres
et moins on aura besoin évidemment aussi
bien au niveau de la santé parce que les
personnes qui qui qui ne vont pas bien
sont souvent euh ont souvent des
problèmes au niveau enfin
oui de manque de de d'échange avec les
autres et et ça ça génère beaucoup de
maladies beaucoup de stress beaucoup de
voilà le lien social pour moi c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui qui doit être
développé et on doit pouvoir aider les
associations qui qui qui prennent en
charge ce genre de chos on aura beaucoup
entendu parler du vivre ensemble autour
de cette table ce soir j' metis Nati
pour le social puis après je pass par
moi j'ai retenu quand même certaines
choses c'est quand même moi après sur
auquel nous nous opposons fermement
c'est la marchandisation qui est faite
au niveau du social et de la santé je
veux dire aujourd'hui on entend parler
de crèches les crèches aujourd'hui ce
sont des crèches qui sont des crèches
privées pour lesquell il faut payer sur
lesquel il y a des listes d'attent sur
lesquelles il y a pas forcément une
vraie politique on va dire au niveau de
la la le schéma le programme de santé au
niveau de l'enfance et autres quand on
parle maisons de retraite aujourd'hui il
y a pas de maison de retraite au niveau
départemental les maisons de retraite
elles sont privées ou associatives donc
derrière c'est une marchandisation de la
santé et ça par contre je suis désolé
c'est pas du tout l'avenir de notre
société je veux dire ça veut dire que
maintenant n on le droit d'être soignés
on le droit d'avoir des enfants on garde
que les gens ont de l'argent c'est pas
ça la solidarité la fraternité dans
notre pays donc là effectivement il y a
de quoi faire il y a de quoi faire il y
a et et si moi je me présente en terme à
ces élections c'est aussi pour faire
entendre une autre une autre voix par
rapport à cela donc vous me Parlier sur
les sujets voilà ce que je peux y
répondre de manière synthétique je
pourrais développer beaucoup plus si si
le temps était donné et non pas compté
et ben non justement
pu il vous en reste il vous en reste pas
beaucoup donc oui sur le principe
effectivement si on parle on parle de de
de de de cette approche là on parle
notamment du de l'approche santé pour
les pour les plus petits la notion de
crèche c'est extrêmement important oui
parce que c'est c'est par là qu'on
démarge c'est la cadrature du cercle et
on finit effectivement avec le côté le
côté maison de retraite où effectivement
le schéma
gérontologi juste je termine juste le
schéma gologique au niveau du
département est bien bien abstrait
Nicolas vous avez vous avez une minute
une petite minute enfin je suis surpris
d'entendre ce que ce que je peux
entendre là enfin je depuis que
leselines sont son ieline le département
est à droite donc je suis assez étonné
de voir qu'aujourd'hui la majorité
sortante fait des propositions qu'elle
n'a pas tenu ou qu'elle n'a pas réalisé
pendant ses dernières années de
mandature donc je enfin je prends acte
et on on pourra voir à l'avenir si
jamais vous êtes élu ce qu'il en viendra
mais je voudrais quand même parce que
Madame colmes verger nous a demandé de
connaître un petit peu mieux
do voudrais juste dire je voudrais juste
voilà je voudrais juste préciser que
quand même dans le département c'est 80
% des plannings familiaux qui sont en
voie de fermeture c'est les PMI sont en
en voie de de diminution de 69 à 20 sur
tout le territoire par exemple sur le
canton de plaisir elles vont passer de 4
à 2 et les centres territoiaux d'AC
sociaux vont disparaître de de 25 %.
nous ce que nous proposons tout
simplement pour garder
monêt du garder un service public du
grand âge un service public de la petite
enfance merci Nicolas Éric Gigou et
Fabien maté je vous passe encore la
parole pour une trentaine de secondes
parce que vous avez du temps de de
retard qu'est-ce que vous votre
conclusion c'est une conclusion ce que
j'allais vous demander c'est une
conclusion à travers ces élections
départementales je pense qu'il y a un un
vrai choix de société et c'est pour ça
que on incite les et on propose et on on
on on soutient les gens pour et on les
on les encourage à à aller à se déplacer
àer voter puisque encore une fois c'est
un vrai choix de de société qui qui
s'impose à travers tout ce qui s'est dit
autour de cette table des choses vont
changer d'ici un horizon assez proche et
donc soit on
continue à détricoter notre notre nation
parce qu'à travers ça c'est bien ça qui
se passe quand on département et cetera
et on envisage des hyperrégions et on
vide de sa substance le rôle de
département aujourd'hui donc ce qui fait
qu'on stérilise un petit peu tout ce qui
a été dit aujourd'hui c'est une
conclusion oui mais c'est fin enfin al
un autre choix c'est de faire rentrer
des élus frond national au vous êtes sur
une discussion plus nationale on a bien
compris un débat parce que parce que la
le l'avenir et le rôle de des
départements est impliqué dans la dans
le déveltional je suis obligé de vous
couper parce qu'on arrive en fin de
cette émission on va jeter un dernier
coup d'œil sur les sur les chronos vous
êtes tout entre 7 et et 8 minutes à peu
près en tout cas je vous remercie à tous
les 6 d'être venu sur le plateau de
téléfil pour parler autour du canton de
de plaisir c'est la fin de cette
émission le débat sera rediffusé aussi
samedi 14 mars à 20h et dimanche 15 mars
à 10h prochain débat ce sera le jeudi 12
mars toujours en direct entre 19h et 20h
et je recevrai l'ensemble des candidats
du canton de saint-ire l'école
excellente soirée à vous
merci
I